we followed the rules
barely a day has passed where we haven't
agonized over that decision
but we did it
because we followed the rules
we all found the rules frustrating at
times
and i'm no exception to that
i had to isolate six times during covid
pulling me away from my work
and the things that i love
but i did it
because we followed the rules
the idea
that i would then casually break those
rules is wrong
and frankly i don't believe those
accusing me
believe it themselves
they are just trying to feed cynicism
to get the public to believe all
politicians are the same
i'm here to say that they're not
i believe in honor
integrity
and the principle
that those who make the laws
must follow them
and i believe that politicians who
undermine that principle
undermine trust in politics undermine
our democracy
and undermine britain
i'm absolutely clear that no laws were
broken
they were followed at all times
i simply had something to eat while
working late in the evening
as any politician would do
days before an election
but if the police decide to issue me
with a fixed penalty notice
i would of course
do the right thing
and step down
this matters
it matters
because the british public deserve
politicians
who think the rules apply to them
they deserve politicians who hold
themselves to the highest standards
and they deserve politicians who put the
country first rather than themselves
they will always
always
get that from me
thank you
i'll now take questions i think
beth we've agreed you'll go first yes
um
when it was announced on friday that you
were going to be investigated by the
police it was pretty clear to everyone
that should you be issued a fixed
penalty notice or even actually you
haven't said this but be found in breach
of lockdown regulations that given what
you've said about the prime minister
you'd have no option but to resign so
what my first question is why did it
take you so long to arrive at that
position is it because you're aware of
the huge gamble that you're taking and
you were frightened by that
beth no rules were broken i've been
absolutely clear about that from start
to finish
and
i've set out today the in-principle
position that i believe in unlike those
at downing street i don't think those
that make the laws can then simply
breach them
and not
take action i believe that if you've
made a law you should respect the law
and if you're found to be in breach of
it you should step down and that's what
i've set out clearly this afternoon it's
a gamble for you though
beth this is a matter of principle and
honour for me it's about who i am what i
stand for
and i stand for honor and integrity
on the belief that
politics is a force for good and we
shouldn't all be dragged down
by this cynical belief that all
politicians are the same and i'm here to
make it clear that i am not the same
we've seen 50 fines in downing street
we've seen a prime minister won't step
down we are not all the same i am
different and i've set out today how i'm
different
i just want one more and then i promise
our hand over on january the 31st you
put out a tweet you said honesty and
decency matter after months of denial
the prime minister is now under criminal
investigation for breaking his own
lockdown laws he needs to do the decent
thing and resign so you said then that
the prime minister should resign because
he was under criminal investigation
which you now are as well
isn't it rather hypocritical
that you said that of him but you're not
prepared to resign right now what do you
say to people that say you're hypocrites
i've set out my position very clearly
i've taken a very different course to
the prime minister of course um did
break the laws and then didn't resign
i'm setting out a very different course
um i have different principles to the
prime minister
and i think it's very important the
public see that not all politicians are
the same i'm very different to the prime
minister in this regard in terms of the
principle the honor and the integrity of
the office that i hold
i think we're going to ben you thank you
um you've portrayed yourself again today
as a politician of integrity you're a
former director too of public
prosecutions
how embarrassed are you angry are you
that your career as labour leader now
hangs on the outcome of a police
investigation
ben
first and foremost no rules were broken
i don't actually believe that those that
are accusing me believe rules were
broken they are trying to simply drag
all politicians into a place where the
public think we're all the same
for me this is an in-principle position
no rules are broken i'm absolutely clear
about that
but in the event that i'm wrong about
that and i get a fixed penalty notice i
will do the right thing and step down do
you think there are people within the
labour party trying to undermine you
with this
but this is my decision about what is
the right thing to do in these
circumstances no rules were broken i've
said that
with great clarity
but this is about me it's about what i
believe in in politics it's about
integrity
and i believe in integrity and integrity
requires me
to take the course of action i've set
out here if in the event i get a fixed
penalty notice
libby do you now accept though that you
jumped the gun in calling for the prime
minister's resignation and the
chancellor's resignation when they were
only under investigation
for breaking the rules well libby i'm
setting out
um my position in relation to
the events of the last few days the
prime minister has chosen
not to resign notwithstanding that
not only has he broken the law that he
made but 50 fines have been imposed in
relation to the workplace that he is
responsible for
that is his choice
but it's very important that the public
don't think that all politicians are the
same and that is why i've set out my
position
in terms of honor and integrity but he
had been found guilty at the time you
called for him to quit that was playing
politics wasn't it and it was bad
politics libby he's been found guilty
he's been found to be in breach of the
law i think over 50 fines now in
relation to downing street
and the prime minister has not stepped
down
he and others in his party want the
public to believe that we're all the
same that we will all act in that way
i'm here to make clear that is not the
case thank you all very much
what happens then do you still resign or
does it have to be a fixed penalty
notice well
i haven't done anything that breaks the
rules
um the penalty for for a covid breach is
a fixed penalty notice that that's a
matter of law um and i've set out what
the position is in relation to that
thank you very much
our political editor beth rigby there
wasn't going to get away that easily so
kirsten there
with that statement that if
if he is issued with a fixed penalty
notice by durham police he will as he
put it do the right thing and step down
as labour leader um in his statement he
said the idea i would casually break the
law is wrong he wants to prove that not
all politicians are the same he said he
believes in honor and integrity and he
believes that politicians who undermine
that undermine democracy
and britain and this matters he said the
public deserved politicians who know the
rules
adhere to them
and
leaders who put the country before
themselves let's bring in our political
correspondent rob powell who was
watching that statement um and rob our
political editor beth rigby was quite
keen um to talk to sakirshama about the
fact that he may not get a fixed penalty
notice however he may be found by police
to have breached covid rules and for
those who remember the barnard castle
incident and dominic cummings that is a
possibility
yeah and that was it's a really crucial
point that was why i think beth was
really keen to put it to secure there
because
of course durham police when they did
look into dominic cummings's infamous
trip to barnard castle the wording was
quite woolly it sort of left him in the
gray zone a little bit because it said
that he might have breached the rules
but it said that if they had stopped him
they would have turned him round but not
necessarily fined him and they weren't
giving out retrospective fines anyway
now it's got to be a possibility that
that is one of the outcomes possible for
kierstarma and up until that point that
beth pinned him down at the end
he hadn't really been very clear about
what he would do in that circumstance i
think we now know what the threshold is
what the line is and that's been drawn
pretty clearly now
that it is a fixed penalty notice that
will trigger that resignation so if he
is issued with that fine then he will
step down as labour leader but if durham
police
find that he has potentially breached
the rules but don't issue with him with
a fine he will presumably carry on now
that could be the sort of worst of both
worlds because the whole point of making
this intervention today and setting this
out was as you heard him saying there to
try and sort of reclaim his mantle as a
man of integrity and put some distance
between him and boris johnson when it
comes to rule breaking um and sort of
try and chip away at the narrative that
has been pretty successfully advanced by
tory mps in the last few weeks that all
them all politicians are the same the
danger is if he gets found to have
potentially been in breach of the rules
but doesn't get a fixed penalty noticed
he'll stay in post but those attacks
will still keep coming
and there will still be potential for
his integrity his honor to be impugned
and the danger for kisakistama is he is
someone that trades off that integrity
very heavily as a politician it's one of
his big political pitches as a leader
really and if he's not got that then he
is i think severely hobbled in terms of
his offer um to the country but i think
labour clearly feeling that they had to
adjust their position that the current
position of basically insisting um that
there was nothing to see here would not
hold and now at least when secure
stamina and labour politicians are faced
with these questions about what happened
in durham um in april of last year at
least they can now say that zakir stama
has set out his stall that if he has
found to have breached rules and gets a
penalty notice he will step down and
crucially as well they can say
that is something that the prime
minister hasn't done so the dream
situation for labour is that he gets an
all-clear from durham police and if
anything he comes out further emboldened
um with a new attack line for boris
johnson and then maybe the calculation
actually was that if he had got a fixed
penalty notice he would have had to
resign anyway that was certainly
the the what sir islam was trying to
portray anyway that this was something
he would have done anyway of course we
can't really know whether that was
actually the truth but i think talking
to labour officials and mps over the
weekend the consensus was very much he
would have to go if he broke the law and
he got a fine so what's the harm in
making the pledge um as well
and potentially getting the upside if
you were cleared of course the danger is
that middle ground though where um he is
accused potentially of wriggling off the
hook of getting out of it on the
technicality if he is found to breach
rules but doesn't get the penalty notice
so
it's a pretty bold intervention a gamble
uh and probably quite an
uncharacteristic one for quite a sort of
steady eddy politician that zakir
starmer is it could pay off and put him
in a much better position but it might
also massively backfire okay rob powell
with the latest there from westminster
uh thank you we'll have more on this
story throughout the afternoon
sakirshama saying he will resign as
labour leader if he is issued with a
fixed penalty notice by durham police
for breaking covid rules laws as they
were at the time
now president putin today attempted to
justify his assault on ukraine claiming
it is a forced response to western plans
to invade russia speaking at the
country's annual vic